und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend mit voller wucht sagte jens
spahn heute rolle die vierte welle der
pandemie die es eigentlich gar nicht
mehr geben dürfte nach einem
dreivierteljahr impfungen die delta
mutationen haben dass wir uns stärker
gemacht und eine impfkampagne die an der
gleichgültigkeit oder dem widerstand der
letzten 25 30 prozent scheitert lässt in
die tore offen
die gemeldeten neuinfektionen die manche
ich auch gestern noch als statistischen
ausreißer sehen wollten sind nicht
besser geworden ganz im gegenteil auf
33.000 gestern folgten heute
37.000 der höchste je gezählte wert und
wieder auch beim vierten mal kommen die
politischen entschlüsse und ihre
umsetzung verdammt spät die
gesundheitsminister von bund und ländern
haben heute die beschlüsse gefasst zu
denen sie gemeinsam in der lage waren ob
das wirklich reichen soll und warum dann
nicht mehr drin war dazu dann der
vorsitzende darunter nach dem bericht
von stefan leifert wo das hauptproblem
liegt konnten die gesundheitsminister
direkt vor ihrem tagungshotel
besichtigen ein im bus offen für alle
die sich impfen lassen wollen doch
gerade mal 15 kamen an einem ganzen tag
die impf kampagne stoppt gewaltig auch
in linda wachsend sorge und ratlosigkeit
die zahlen galoppieren davon die
intensivstationen füllen sich die
krankenhausbetten füllen sich und
deswegen ist die gesamte gesellschaft
aufgefordert jetzt alles zu tun um die
infektion einzudämmen vor allem die
politik ist aufgefordert die runde der
gesundheitsminister ist angesichts der
wucht der neuen welle zur runde der
ratlosen geworden einschwören auf einen
harten winter mal wieder
wir merken aber jetzt dass diese vierte
welle mit voller wucht
kommt dass sie deutlich an fahrt
aufgenommen hat vor uns liegen sehr
schwere wochen das zeichnet sich allein
schon durch die hohen infektionszahlen
ab die deutschlandkarte zeigt die
dramatik der lage die sieben tage
incidents erreicht immer neue
höchstwerte steigt aber nicht überall
gleich auch die impfquote ist ungleich
niedrige impfquote gleich hohe instanzen
das ist die logik der pandemie
auffrischungsimpfungen für alle nach
sechs monaten sind der zentrale
beschluss dieses krisengipfels an die
zehn millionen menschen könnten damit
schon heute den im kloster erhalten
wichtig ist die botschaft
dass auffrischungsimpfungen vom
grundsatz nach sechs monaten für alle
möglich sein sollen insbesondere
natürlich für die gruppen medizinisches
personal ältere menschen aber wir wollen
damit ganz stark in diese welle
reingehen immer lauter wird die
forderung nach strengeren kontrollen von
im pfund test nachweisen auch der
ausschluss von ungeimpften aus
gastronomie und großveranstaltungen die
zweijährige ist kein tabu mehr
das 2g geimpft und genesen in bestimmten
lagen hohe infektionszahlen hohe
belastung gesundheitswesens daneben auch
regelhaft eine option sein soll für die
zugangsbeschränkung zu bestimmten
veranstaltungen restaurants und anderes
mehr sachsen geht damit heute vor
anführt zweig landesweit für gastronomie
und großveranstaltungen ein es ist auch
das eingeständnis eines scheiterns das
ist eines der probleme die wir
tatsächlich in sachsen haben das ist
nicht geschafft haben in den letzten
wochen und monaten tatsächlich einen
schutzwall zu bilden aus geimpften geben
dafür da sind dass man die menschen die
eben ein sehr hohes alter haben die
vorerkrankungen haben die zu den wohnort
den gruppen gehören die sich nicht
impfen lassen können dass wir die
schützen die korona pandemie ist mit
voller wucht zurück der politik fehlen
die rezepte und ein krisen winter steht
bevor das sind die bitteren erkenntnisse
der gesundheitsminister in lindau
wir erreichen den bayerischen
gesundheitsminister und vorsitzenden der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz der länder
in seiner heimat guten abend alle
guten abend herr kleber
20 monate nach beginn der pandemie
dreiviertel jahr nach beginn der
massenhaften impfung ist die lage wieder
fast zu ernst oder vielleicht sogar
ernster als je zuvor warum bekommt man
das nicht in den griff die lage ist
ernst und in manchen regionen teilweise
dramatisch das muss man leider
konstatieren die krankenhäuser laufen
voll die intensivstationen sind belegt
und wir müssen handeln und wir waren uns
bei den ministerinnen und minister sehr
sehr einig dass wir jetzt alle
kraftanstrengungen aufwenden müssen um
diese welle wieder zu brechen nun ist
das schnell gesagt aber wenn man dann
auf die maßnahmen kommt die sie
beschlossen haben wirken die doch wieder
halbherzig es war die rede davon unter
umständen nur noch genesene und geimpfte
zu bestimmten dingen einzulassen und
tests sollten nicht mehr gelten das ist
nicht beschlossen worden die impfungen
die jetzt dringend fällig sind vor allen
dingen bei den zehn millionen die immer
noch voll der adel sind drei viertel von
ihnen bisher nicht geimpft selbst diese
impfungen mit offensichtlich
impfwilligen gehen nicht voran so könnte
man eine durchgehend warum ist noch
nicht bundesweit anerkannt dass die lage
verdammt ernst ist in manchen gebieten
einfach ein paar wochen früher als in
anderen
also ich glaube wir haben gute
beschlüsse gefasst das thema der booster
impfungen die für alle möglich sein
sollen wenn sechs monate vergangen sind
nach der vollständigen impfung sind ganz
wichtiges signal gerade auch für die
variablen gruppen wir sind in den
altenheimen und pflegeheimen drin mit
den auffrischungsimpfungen die daten aus
israel zeigen da glaube ich dass wir da
wirklich die welle noch mal brechen
können wir haben das testsystem
nachgeschärft wir wollen gerade in alten
und pflegeheimen
auch wenn jemand geimpft und genießen
ist noch mal einen test auch mit
aufsätzen und haben insgesamt gesagt
zweig ist durchaus ein thema das in
manchen regionen zum tragen kommen kann
auch wir in bayern haben bei der
ampelschaltung auf rot das thema 2 geht
durchaus mit auf dem plan auf dem plan
aber noch nicht sofort
doch wir haben mit den hot spots wo die
ampel schon auf rot ist wird in
bestimmten bereichen das thema zweig
auch schon angewendet wir müssen ja
sehen wir planen das thema impfen das
unterscheidet uns von den anderen wellen
und jetzt merken wir dass die
intensivstationen voll sind und wir
müssen anderen und das tun wir auch und
wir waren ganz entschlossen und
geschlossen heute auch bei den
ministerinnen und minister und wir
wollen die welle wirklich noch einmal
mit aller macht brechen sie haben auch
keine wahl die erfahrung zeigt dass ein
prozent der infizierten in sieben bis
zehn tagen auf der intensivstation
landen wie lange halten sie das noch aus
die frage ist wie lange auch die
pflegekräfte es aushalten und die dort
dienst tun hatten heute eine pflegekraft
dabei die uns sehr eindringlich noch
einmal die situation geschildert hat
deswegen müssen wir alles tun um auch
die pflegekräfte und die stationen zu
entlasten dort sind vorwiegend
ungeimpfte menschen ich möchte die
chance auch noch mal nutzen zu
appellieren das thema impfen ist der weg
aus der pandemie wir haben gesehen dass
jetzt noch mal wirklich die überlegung
sein muss ich lasse mich impfen impfen
ist keine privatsache impfen ist auch
ein thema für die jetzt für die ganze
gesellschaft nun werden sie in weniger
in kurzer zeit wahrscheinlich in eine
situation kommen wo das was sie schon
oft angedeutet haben umgesetzt werden
muss das heißt es gibt ein shut down
oder lockdown wie sie sagen der nur für
die ungeimpften gilt die anderen das
weiß man sind so geschützt und dass man
sie weiter ins theater ins kino in die
clubs und den kneipen gehen lassen kann
die anderen bleiben dann draußen wird es
darauf hinauslaufen
ich denke dass das was wir sehen dass
geimpfte und genesene ihre rechte auch
nicht mehr eingeschränkt bekommen können
klar ist ich glaube das ist auch
rechtlich nicht mehr haltbar so müssen
maßnahmen wirken in den anderen bereich
vor allem weil ja auch die ungeimpften
das gesundheitssystem im moment
überlasten und das ist das signal an
dieser stelle und deswegen wird das
maßnahmenbündel auch sich in dem bereich
bewegen wird irgendwann am horizont wenn
die lage sich weiter so zuspitzt dann
doch einmal eine impfpflicht stehen
müssen
das thema der impfpflicht ist ein thema
das wir ja im moment ausgeschlossen
haben noch wir wollen alles dafür tun
mit den argumenten noch einmal zu
überzeugen ich nehme aber war dass in
der gesellschaft die diskussion fahrt
aufnimmt dass auch aus der wissenschaft
aus anderen bereichen dieses thema immer
mehr kommt im moment wollen wir es noch
bei der freiwilligkeit belassen und
versuchen mit den argumenten zu
überzeugen
aber ich hoffe dass diese argumente auch
wirklich noch ankommen im moment haben
sie gesagt und wir haben es deutlich
gehört danke schön herr holetschek einen
guten abend noch
guten abend und wir hatten das gespräche
am frühen abend wir sind immer noch in
der schwierigen lage dass impfungen die
einzige verteidigung gegen das virus
sind wenn menschen erst mal krank
geworden sind gibt es kein heilmittel
das könnte sich ändern gestern hat das
unternehmen merck in großbritannien eine
zulassung bekommen für ein medikament
mit immerhin eine halbierung der
sterberate und heute legt eine
konkurrenz noch deutlich kraftvoller
nach der us pharmariese pfizer berichtet
von einer erfolgreichen klinischen
studie die pille mit dem namen pak
slowik habe hohe wirksamkeit gezeigt
weise will nun die zulassung zunächst in
den usa beantragen wegen der klaren
datenlage sei die studie vorzeitig
beendet worden von 1200 infizierten
ungeimpften patienten musste weniger als
ein prozent ins krankenhaus keiner starb
so kaiser die verhandlungen über die
ampel koalition kommen zwei wochen nach
beginn offenbar ins stocken die grünen
sehen beim thema klimaschutz probleme
parteichefin baerbock sagte im rbb
klimaschutz dürfe nicht nur sache einer
partei sein sondern müsse sich quer
durch die ganze künftige regierung
ziehen es sei unklar ob der
koalitionsvertrag wie geplant bis ende
des monats stehen spd und fdp äußerten
sich dagegen zuversichtlich den zeitplan
einzuhalten
am 6 dezember soll olaf scholz zum neuen
kanzler gewählt werden der neue
bundesratspräsident
ramelow sieht die künftige
bundesregierung vor großen
herausforderungen
sie müsste die ökologische und digitale
modernisierung voranbringen und dabei
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse
sicherstellen sagte er in seiner
antrittsrede
die länderkammer stimmte zudem der neuen
heizkostenverordnung zu neu installierte
zähler müssen aus der ferne ablesbar
sein alte geräte sollen bis ende 2026
ausgetauscht werden die rechnung muss
den vergleich zum vormonat zum vorjahr
und den durchschnittsverbrauch zeigen
spd und linke in mecklenburg vorpommern
haben ihre koalitionsverhandlungen
inhaltlich abgeschlossen
ministerpräsidentin schwesig und linken
landtagsfraktionschef in oldenburg
erklärten es gebe keine strittigen
punkte mehr außerordentliche parteitage
sollen samstag kommen der woche über den
entwurf des koalitionsvertrages beraten
im fall der zustimmung will sich
schwesig am 15 november zur wiederwahl
stellen
in berlin ist unter ungeklärten
umständen ein russischer diplomat mitte
oktober am botschaftsgebäude ums leben
gekommen heute berichtet der spiegel
darüber und dass der 35-jährige
verbindungen zum russischen
inlandsgeheimdienst fsb gehabt haben
soll den deutschen sicherheitsbehörden
sei er als spion bekannt gewesen das
auswärtige amt will sich zu dem fall
nicht äußern
auch vor dem hintergrund der durch den
sogenannten tiergarten mord belasteten
beziehungen zu russland
die katholische kirche in frankreich hat
eine institutionelle verantwortung für
den massenhaften missbrauch von kindern
und jugendlichen eingeräumt einer
kürzlich vorgelegten studie zufolge geht
es um bis zu
330.000 missbrauchsopfer seit 1950 der
vorsitzende der französischen
bischofskonferenz
sagte mentalitäten und praxis in der
katholischen kirche hätten es ermöglicht
dass es zu diesen taten gekommen sei und
transparenz und verfolgung der täter
verhindert das anerkennen der
verantwortung beinhalte die pflicht zur
entschädigung
alexander lukaschenko der diktator von
belarus hat bis jetzt allen drohungen
und sanktionen des westens gegen sein
regime standgehalten und
perfektioniert gerade sein druckmittel
gegen vor allem deutschland seien hebel
ist das schicksal von flüchtlingen vor
allem aus syrien afghanistan
und irak lässt sie großzügig und
problemlos auch per flugzeug nach
belarus einreißen er weiß ja dass von
den migranten kaum jemand dort bleiben
will ihr fluchtpunkt liegt weit westlich
davon hinter polen in deutschland
jan meyer berichtet aus frankfurt oder
die folgen sind immer stärker spürbar
dort der anruf eines anwohners führt die
bundespolizisten in einem wohngebiet in
frankfurt an der oder hier greifen sie
zwei junge männer aus dem irak auf die
sind aus polen gekommen und haben nun
offensichtlich ihr ziel erreicht im
polizeiwagen werden sie zur feststellung
ihrer identität in die nächste
dienststelle gebracht
in dem sie auch nach der ersten sichtung
jetzt hinweise darauf ergeben dass er
über weißrussland nach europa kommen ist
für beide besteht der verdacht dass eine
einreise und aufenthalt die
bundespolizei an der grenze wurde um 8
100 schafften verstärkt seit dieser
woche überprüft sie gemeinsam mit dem
bundesamt für migration alle ankömmlinge
in einer zentralen registrierungsstelle
in frankfurt oder die meisten
flüchtlinge bleiben und nicht mehr wie
bisher in der region sondern werden
schnell auf alle bundesländer verteilt
eine deutliche entlastung für
brandenburg aber noch lange keine
entwarnung
wir haben sehr hohen migrationsdruck
hier an der deutsch polnischen grenze
wir haben weiter nicht den eindruck dass
die lage sich entspannt also die diese
situation bleibt so uns erstmal
unvermindert hoch noch im juli war die
lage ruhig doch seit august steigen die
zahlen sprunghaft an im oktober wurden
fast 5300 unerlaubte grenzübertritte
registriert deutschland hält seine
grenze nach polen weiter offen für
jedermann auch für flüchtlinge ganz
anders sieht es an der polnischen ostsee
aus sie wird mit stacheldraht gesichert
genau das wird auch in deutschland
politisch gefordert
die sicherung der außengrenzen ist dann
nötig wenn sie gerade wie in diesem fall
gezielt von nachbarstaaten missbraucht
werden für ein ein teil einer übrigen
kriegsführung lukaschenko stellt den
flüchtlingen einen leichten weg aus
belarus in die europäische union in
aussicht die folge verzweifelte szenen
an der polnischen grenze
der machthaber missbraucht flüchtlinge
als druckmittel so wie vor ihm der
türkische präsident erdogan und jetzt
sind nach armada lukaschenko die sehen
hören können sie einmal probieren die
europäische union zu erpressen erpresst
werden kann man nur wenn man nicht
bereit ist flüchtlinge zu schützen asyl
zu gewähren rechtsstaatlichkeit zu
achten polen regelt seiner ostgrenze
immer mehr ab doch noch schaffte es
täglich über 100 flüchtlinge bis nach
brandenburg das bedeutet vorerst weiter
viel arbeit für die bundespolizei an der
grenze zu polen
vor zwei wochen ist die alte
industriestadt glasgow der brennpunkt
für die bemühungen der welt um eine
antwort auf den weltweiten klimawandel
zwei wochen lang malt nun das komplexe
räderwerk der klimadiplomatie um etwas
greifbares auf die beine zu stellen das
ist ein apparat der nicht gebaut ist für
die kreativität und die geschwindigkeit
die jetzt eigentlich gebraucht wurde
diese art von zusammenstehen und von
bedingungsloser anerkennung der
wissenschaft hat bisher nur die jugend
der welt auf die beine gebracht freude
ist for future sie sehen mit allem
tiefen ernst ihre zukunft untergehen und
brachten heute in glasgow ihre
enttäuschung ihrer erwartungen und ihre
wut auf die straße andreas stammen
berichtet
gegen alle widerstände eine
sisyphos-arbeit vielleicht wirklich
vergeblich an drossel und seine familie
auf den letzten metern zur ersten großen
demo beim weltklimagipfel
1500 kilometer ist der gelaufen
paderborn glasgow in seiner metallkugel
die ein zeichen dafür sei dass wir alle
verbunden sind es nur gemeinsam gehe die
politik habe das immer noch nicht
verstanden und die jungen müssen mit den
folgen leben das will er nicht
akzeptieren
gefühl ist dass ich so dass dies
auszubauen haben das ist ich habe auch
drei kinder
und die machen sich natürlich auch
gedanken und mein sohn der hat mit mir
die kugel gebaut und mich sieben wochen
lang begleitet mit dem fahrrad und der
funke muss auch zu unserer generation
überspringen und nicht nur zu ein paar
weil die jungen schon bewusstsein haben
und mit ihren eltern darüber reden nach
am ende zur politik
muss unbedingt zur politik überspringen
der tag der jugend in glasgow friday is
for future ruft und 10.000 nicht nur
junge klimaaktivisten folgen enttäuscht
von den bislang mageren ergebnissen der
konferenz dass 15 grad ziel in weiter
entfernung stillstand aber aufgeben
wollen und können sie nicht
die aufmerksamkeit die eine
klimakonferenz auf die umweltkrise
richtet ist immer ein gewinn das klima
aktivisten im fokus stehen ist immer gut
aber das was die politik in den
konferenzräumen zustande gebracht hat
ist nicht von großer bedeutung
wir müssen weiter hoffen sonst bleibt in
der klimakrise nur noch
die hoffnung verloren hat die ikone der
klimabewegung mit den mächtigen bild
greta thunberg nicht mehr sprechen
zeitverschwendung
die weltklimakonferenz ist zu einer pr
veranstaltung geworden mit schönen reden
der politiker schönen ankündigungen
verpflichtungen und zielen zwei wochen
feiert man hier das weiter so und
blablabla
die die noch am dialog interessiert sind
präsentieren am mittag
un-generalsekretär gute risch und kopf
26 präsident schama die forderungen der
jungen 77 seiten zusammengetragen mit
hilfe von 40.000 jungen menschen auf der
ganzen welt
kommt wieder in die ablage ungelesen auf
den straßen glasgow es das
vorherrschende gefühl bei jung und alt
wird die hoffnung die alle schon in
kopenhagen hat was ja schon elf jahre
elf jahre her als immer wieder hat man
das gefühl man wird vertröstet auf das
nächste jahr auf große mutige schritte
warnten sie auch diesmal wohl wieder
vergeblich die katastrophe immer
schneller auf alle zur asse
der aus den klimaschutz vorhaben
resultierende
transformationsprozess ist eine große
herausforderung für wirtschaft und
gesellschaft wie gross zeigt sich
derzeit exemplarisch im
volkswagen-konzern der umbau zur
e-mobilität verändert und bedroht auch
arbeitsplätze valerie haller und das ist
auch nur ein kritikpunkt der belegschaft
ja bei vw ist ein offener streit darüber
ausgebrochen wie der konzern eben genau
diesen wandel zur e mobilität schaffen
soll es wird sogar spekuliert dass der
stuhl von vorstandschef dies wackelt er
scheint den mächtigen betriebsrat gegen
sich zu haben doch dies liegt noch mal
nach volkswagen müsse sich grundlegend
ändern um in beinharten wettbewerb mit
tesla bestehen zu können die produktion
von e autos kostet jobs denn sie ist
weit weniger aufwendig viele teile
fallen weg anlasser ein spritzer tank
oder auspuff ein verbrenner motor
braucht zehn mal mehr teile als ein e
antrieb mittelfristig wird die arbeit im
stammwerk wolfsburg knapp weil
vorprodukte fehlen muss vw zur zeit
immer wieder kurzarbeit beantragen aus
sicht des betriebsrats sind die
produktionsstraßen aber auch strategisch
nicht ausgelastet das erste e-auto soll
in wolfsburg erst in fünf jahren vom
band laufen und e autos bekommen im
volkswagen konzern immer mehr gewicht
zwischen januar und september lieferte
vw weltweit fast 140 prozent mehr autos
aus als im gleichen zeitraum vor einem
jahr volkswagen hat das ehrgeizige ziel
ganz vorn dabei zu sein bei der
e-mobilität da ist tesla der maßstab der
amerikanische hersteller produziert
seine autos mit deutlich weniger
mitarbeitern im september hatte dies
gedroht 30.000 jobs in deutschland zu
streichen die verunsicherung unter den
vw mitarbeitern ist groß vielen dank
valerie nach frankfurt seit den 1990 er
jahren wird über eine aufspaltung der
bahn diskutiert derzeit ist die
forderung auch thema der
koalitionsverhandlungen
sowohl grüne als auch fdp wollen
bahnnetz und betrieb trennen die spd ist
allerdings dagegen heute hat sich nun
auch die monopolkommission für eine
zerschlagung ausgesprochen auch der
fahrgastverband pro bahn ist dafür der
dringend notwendige ausbau der gleis
infrastruktur dürfe nicht weiter durch
betriebswirtschaftliche erwägungen
eingeschränkt werden
der flug des deutschen astronaut
matthias maurer zur internationalen
raumstation iss wegen des schlechten
wetters in florida erneut verschoben
worden der saarländer soll nun
frühestens am montagabend von cape
canaveral aus richtung iss aufbrechen
die endgültige entscheidung soll in den
nächsten tagen fallen auch die jetzige
crew der iss wartet auf ihren flug
zurück zur erde die nasa prüft eine
baldige rückkehr womöglich noch vor
maurers abflug
und zu guter letzt gibt es jetzt etwas
zu feiern den hundertsten geburtstag
einer wunderbaren frau mit einem großen
herzen und einer schier unerschöpflichen
energie das größte geschenk ist eines
von ihr an deutschland dass margot
friedländer hier lebt mit 88 jahren aus
new york zurückgekehrt in das land wo
die herrschende mörderische bande wollte
dass sie stirbt im kz wie ihr jüngerer
bruder und ihre eltern und millionen
andere juden aber sie hat überlebt all
das das kz theresienstadt und das ganze
naziregime um jetzt ihre geschichte
denen zu erzählen die durch diese
geschichte für immer immun werden sollen
gegen hass auf andere nicola albrecht
feiert ihr leben
als wäre es gestern gewesen erinnert
sich margot friedländer was im januar
1943 hier in berlin geschah ihr jüngerer
bruder wird von der gestapo verhaftet
die mutter versucht ihm zur seite zu
stehen margot sieht sie nie wieder eine
letzte botschaft der mutter übermittelt
ihr eine nachbarin wenn sie meine
tochter sehen sagen sie ja ich gehe mit
reis wohin auch immer das sein mag sie
soll versuchen ihr leben zu machen
mutter und bruder werden in auschwitz
ermordet die botschaft der mutter wird
margot leitmotiv mehr als ein jahr lang
schafft sie es sich zu verstecken dann
wird auch margot verhaftet und nach
theresienstadt deportiert dort lernt sie
ihren zukünftigen mann kennen nach der
befreiung wandern sie gemeinsam in die
usa aus leben ein amerikanisches leben
er ist 57 jahre später im jahr 2003
reist sie das erste mal wieder nach
berlin
das war der punkt der mein leben
verändert hat wo ich in eine stadt
gekommen wobei die wurzeln sind
ein paar jahre später fasst sie einen
entschluss
neuanfang mit 88 jahren margot sie
zurück nach berlin ins land der täter in
ihrer heimat wie ich meine deutsche
staatbürgerschaft
zurückbekommen habe sie erwartet jetzt
dass ich danke schön sagen das tue ich
nicht denn sie geben wir ja nur zurück
was sie mir weggenommen haben auch
kursstürze
und sie engagiert sich gönnt sich keine
pause besucht bis heute schulklassen
erzählt ihre geschichte beantwortet
fragen immer und immer wieder
ich bin zurückgekommen um mit euch zu
sprechen
euch die hand zu reichen
aber euch zu bitten dass ihr
zeugnis geben soll wir könnten nicht
mehr sehr lange machen wie
sterben aus ich sage immer es gibt kein
christliches kein jüdisches kein
muslimisches blut es gibt nur menschlich
das blut selbst corona kann margot nicht
stoppen dialog digital mit 100 jahren
für sie kein problem
margot terminkalender ist voll
ihre zeit ist ein geschenk und margot
nimmt sich zeit selten für sich immer
für alle
es gibt mir auch kraft wenn ihr mich
anhört wenn ich es nicht alle erreichen
kann aber wenn ich zwei oder drei
erreiche das wasserrecht weil es für
äußerst
[Musik]
herzlichen glückwunsch und auch noch
einen tollen geschmack bei der auswahl
von boten von jüdischen freunden in
amerika habe ich die weisheit dass die
beste rache ein schönes leben sei und
das wäre margot friedländer von herzen
gegangen noch viele jahre in vielen
solchen augenblicken aber für das was
ihre familie erlebt hat kann es einen
ausgleich geben um so großherziger ihr
geschenk an uns tolle geschichte
sein könnte mir meldet sich hier um 0.10
mit unserem heute schon mal update bis
morgen schönes wochenende
[Musik]
guten abend in fast ganz
kontinentaleuropa liegen morgennebels
temperaturen zwischen 5 und 15 grad
kälter ist es im norden skandinaviens
wärme an der algarve und auch am
östlichen mittelmeer am westlichen
mittelmeer dagegen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen morgen auch nur bei
15 grad und das liegt an einem tief dass
ich dort entwickelt hat und dass uns
auch am wochenende dort kräftige
unwetter bringen wird über nordeuropa
ziehen einige tiefs hinweg die bringen
regen mit das merken wir auch in
deutschland und der süden profitiert von
einem hoch über dem atlantik heute nacht
fällt entlang der küsten von nord- und
ostsee in schleswig-holstein etwas regen
im süden ist es klar da bildet sich auch
mal nebel so sind die temperaturen ganz
unterschiedlich im süden südlich von
main und mosel sinken sie auf plus 3 bis
minus 5 grad am boden wird es dann
frostig in norddeutschland bleibt es
milder bei sieben bis neun grad und über
tag wird es da kaum wärmer da erwarten
uns werte zwischen 9 und 11 grad im
süden wird es deutlich wärmer ist es in
der nacht war mit höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 5 und 10 grad in süddeutschland
gibt es entweder zehn nebelfelder oder
strahlenden sonnenschein das dann vor
allen dingen am alpenrand und auf den
berggipfel in der mitte wechseln sonne
und wolken miteinander ab im norden ist
es bedeckt und in mecklenburg vorpommern
schleswig holstein kann es etwas regnen
am sonntag ziehen die kräftigen
regenfälle weiter nach süden dahinter
gibt es kräftige schauer und gewitter
bei einem starken bis stürmischen
westwind im süden ändert sich wenig in
der nacht zu montag droht dann an der
nordsee vielleicht eine sturmflut und
eher ruhig geht es dann in der woche
weiter guten abend